it's like living with a like a leash on
a little bit you can do some stuff but
every now and then you remember that
it's there I was living in Japan during
the earthquake in 2011 a few weeks and
months of political unrest while I was
living overseas we lived with bags by
the door ready to go in case you needed
to get out
I found out in 2008 I had PTSD complex
PTSD but I think the diagnosis should
have probably been made when I was 14
years old I was braked and as a result I
live with PTSD the civil war in Lebanon
broke out in 1975 I was only 17 years
old I lived through that for about 12
years as it kind of sunk in I started to
feel really guilty because I had always
associated PTSD with people I'd been to
war and I just didn't think I deserved
it
the BTS D triggers they ambush you are
you don't know when it's gonna come in
sort of the unknown every day you wake
up and you don't know if you're going to
have a trigger today I was at a movie
and there's a part where this woman got
trapped in a car I had a serious panic
attack there's a song that was talking
about like shooting and armed robbery
and just hearing that song like that was
all it took something happened when I
was 13 and when my trigger happens in
that moment I am 13 usually the sounds
of jet planes overhead would trigger off
the memory for me of those days it would
make me feel weak in the legs and my
memory will go back to that time trying
to look after my children when they were
little and protect them all I had to do
is hear a jet plane and and that's where
my mind will go at times it is literally
felt like I'm dying you feel like this
is this you're never going to get past
this one of the things that's helped me
a lot was group therapy this happened
some more people than you think I sought
to have a conversation with this thing
that you have I did counselling for two
years in college I felt like that got my
life into a pretty manageable place I am
trying to build up the courage to attend
a support group I would have these days
where you're just like you know there's
nothing I can do to do anything that
you're supposed to do in group therapy
someone called it a lost day it's such a
simple thing but putting the words lost
day to those days helped me like
overcome and I think accepting that is
really important and just being like
it's okay to like freak out and just be
like oh this is scary like is it scary
and don't ever tell them to get over it
because it's extremely painful
it takes practice and it takes patience
and it takes faith you have to know that
the fact that you've been through
something so traumatic and you're here
you are much stronger than you think you
are don't feel guilty when you have a
good day give yourself time to heal
you can't judge yourself for it it'll
never be the same but it can get better
and it's worth whatever it's going to
take you can't have a better life there
is a light at the end of the tunnel you
just got to find the right thing that
works for you and getting help is not a
sign of weakness it takes a lot of
strength and a lot of courage and you
deserve the happiness that comes with
getting better my name is Kate my name
is Tammy my name is Kirk and I live with
PTSD ASD